myanmar's junta leader minong lai
inaugurates new military ships that was
just days before his neighboring
southeast asian nations excluded him
from a regional summit this week
it's viewed as a potential watershed
moment for the block of 10 nations known
as asean as it's very rare for it to
take such a strong stance against one of
its own
menanglai staged a coup in february
after the opposition won a landslide
election victory led by onsong tsuchi he
called the election flawed and has since
led a crackdown killing hundreds of
people and jailing thousands
some see this as a foothold for the bloc
to take a more robust and unified
positions in the future including on
issues outside the region
the implications of the consequences of
disinviting myanmar and getting through
that uh and prevailing if you will and i
think that will build more more of an
appetite
more
emboldened asean to take on the more
equally or more important issues of the
day there will be instances instances
where
asean and its member states
can't afford to be neutral
and those instances will involve large
economic and military powers within the
region and the superpowers the united
states and china
while asean members have been divided
about china's territorial claims in the
south china sea recent military
posturing around the korean peninsula
and taiwan has prompted a steep increase
in tension and military buildup that has
made its way south
many militaries within asean are now
intent on buying the latest weapon
technology and expanding their
capabilities like submarines and
unmanned surveillance
but purchasing many of these weapons
comes with strings attached training and
installation by military advisers
usually mean involving a country outside
the region
and concerns over lack of transparency
within the 10 asean members about the
new technology and weapons assay members
are moving forward to acquire some of
these without any agreement on how
the
issues like trust
mistrust can be handled
how the issues of dynamics between
different superpowers supplying
different
arms supplies to different countries can
be
an impact
for
relations among members but many of the
asean nations are still struggling with
the pandemic as new waves continue to
break out and vaccine rates remain low
so governments might face public
resistance if they start spending
billions of dollars on weapons and not
on restarting economies and reopening
borders scott heiler al jazeera bangkok
and florence louis joins us live now
from kuala lumpur florence myanmar
clearly the hot topic on the agenda at
the summit but asean has excluded the
junta leader
that's right and that's a rare and bold
move by an organization that's known for
its main principle of non-interference
in its member states domestic affairs
but some member countries of asean felt
there was a need to send a strong
message to myanmar for failing to
implement an asean-led peace plan and
there was particularly unhappiness and
the fact that an asean-appointed envoy
was not allowed to meet with deposed
civilian leader aung san tsuchi so asean
decided earlier this month that instead
of inviting jun to achieve minong lang
it would invite a non-political
representative now asean
myanmar beggie pardon struck a defiant
tone on the eve of the meeting um its
junta leader said that political rep
that attendance or participation at the
summit would be by myanmar's head of
state or a ministerial representative
and the junta also accused
of accused asean of failing to abide by
its charter now myanmar stand is that
the violence in the country is being
provoked by who they call terrorists
it's a point supported by a shadow
government um opposed to the coup and
they
said that asean has not taken this into
account now the next question then is
what happens next with asean i mean i
imagine myanmar will be part of the
discussion and some analysts have said
that pressure by asean alone is not
going to be enough to bring peace there
has to be broader pressure from the
international community that too is
going to be um something that's going to
be quite difficult to achieve
considering especially that myanmar has
had a history of enduring international
isolation yeah florence and many asian
countries are still struggling with
coronavirus so what else would be on the
agenda then
that's right so they're probably also
going to talk about the economy that is
usually up for discussion um
i imagine they want to focus on
strengthening supply chains we've heard
the singapore prime minister talk about
this
these weaknesses have been exposed
during the pandemic they'll also want to
talk about strengthening or making
public health systems more resilient so
that countries will be able to be better
prepared in dealing with the next health
crisis and then there's also probably
going to be discussion about the rivalry
between us and china now asean countries
have said before that they don't want to
have to choose between the us and china
china is in its own backyard it's also a
very important trade partner for many
asean member countries if not all and
the us is also a traditional ally for
many of the asean members now for the
first time in four years u.s president
will be taking part in the asean summit
joe biden will be joining via video
conference later on tuesday in contrast
former u.s president donald trump
skipped the event four times during his
term now this asean meeting is also
taking place in the wake of a new
security alliance known as orcas this is
a trilateral security pact between the
us uk and australia
for the indo-pacific region and i think
member states are going to want to
discuss this um some member states have
expressed concerns about this they're
probably going to want to say that this
region they want to preserve peace and
stability in this region and probably
even express concern about security
build up in the region all right
florence louie live was there in the
malaysian capital kuala lumpur florence
thank you